all right Eric Repair is considered one
of the world's most renowned top chefs
the Award winner is co-owner of la
Bernadin in New York City that legendary
seafood restaurant has maintained a
three-star Michelin rating that is the
highest possible for 14 consecutive
years it was named the best restaurant
in the world by the least a French
organization that reviews nearly 16,000
restaurants worldwide Eric repair is
here for an interview you'll see only on
CBS this morning a friend of our show so
good to see you chef great to see you
wow what does it mean to be named one
number one in the world it's it's a big
deal of course and it's a great
encouragement for the team that strive
every day for excellence and we are
today celebrating because we don't take
any awards or or rewards for granted and
it's something very special
you know chef what you have achieved is
so remarkable but also not only just for
one year your ability to do this for so
many years to achieve that level of
excellence what would you attribute that
to you have to surround yourself with
people who are loyal very good at what
they do we are passionate and when you
have a good team like that in a dining
room of course and in the kitchen and
everywhere actually in offices
everywhere the first experience is when
you call the restaurant someone has to
be nice to you you don't want a robot to
answer your questions that you don't
want someone who's brutal so the entire
team that we have is is really really
making the success of Lebanon and I'm
lucky to be the one who represents them
today with with you and consumers
obviously have become much more food
savvy as well the role of social media
has really gotten your name out there
how do you continue to evolve and into
impress consumers so the idea is to make
people happy and for them to have a
great meal now of course we use social
media and everything to promote the
response but our
daily routine is to forget about all the
media to focus on our passion to focus
on making sure that we deliver an
experience to the clients that is a very
unique experience that includes
obviously the food that has to be
excellent but but it's much more than
that in the presentation as well I mean
look at Grandma how many people take
pictures of their food right that's
really a work of art and so the question
that I would have is what is the
creative process that you undertake when
you're creating a dish for people so
because we live in New York and we are
surrounded by different cultures and I
see so many chefs with different
ingredients and different techniques it
inspire us to keep our roots which is
based in French tradition but at the
same time it inspired us to explore and
have some influence from Asia and South
America in Europe I happen to travel not
too much but enough to be inspired when
I come back from my trips I'm like oh
let's try this and that and that's what
becomes Libya northern style it's a it's
really a New York restaurant that has a
sense of place
and when you come to the Vienna eyes
it's what you feel like you and the food
represents that Eric let me ask you in
June of course we lost Anthony Bourdain
yes and I know you were his dear friend
for 20 years
I know you have not yet spoken sort of
publicly but how are you doing and I'm
doing very good and yes with Anthony we
had 20 years of friendship and
friendship of course of television and
and on television because I was invited
on the show many times and we were
traveling and it was always tremendous
fun we also had a show called good and
evil and we went through the u.s. 30 CDs
we were actually amazed that the shows
were sold out in theatres and he really
mastered the art of storytelling through
food of course
talk about your experience with him and
traveling the world and meeting so many
different people and their customs
through their cuisine yes Anthony was
very curious by nature very respectful
of cultures and he wanted to share with
the public his discoveries
the idea was do not be scared of
travelling and do not be scared of going
to other countries and do not stay at
the resort do not stay at the hotel and
eat the normal menu just go out go in
the streets engage with people try the
food and learn the culture from from
that experience and I think it is really
well in breaking walls right in between
US and other countries that we sometimes
are a bit scared or nervous to to visit
and that was really a great part of his
legacy yeah and he really didn't hold
much back right I mean he ever
criticized you are cooking no we used to
play pranks on each other and then we
used to have a lot of fun but never
criticize my food before we go one last
thing what's the one ingredient we
should all have in our kitchen olive oil
olive oil it's very healthy
it's very tasty you can apply it on so
many great dishes on salad on fish on
and it makes every vegetable taste
better and I know you're working on a
vegetable book as well yes
underrated food yes great to have you
congratulations congratulations on
everything for one